thank you people
i appreciate it braving all the
protocols the mass the separate thank
you so much for doing all this [ __ ]
um i mean necessary [ __ ]
but uh geez i was disappointed it was
supposed to be a debate last night right
and then you know trump got covered and
then they said you have to do it on zoom
he said i'm not doing that so they had
good grandpa and bad grandpa
had dueling town halls it was i had a
flashback to the 70s when the only
choice on tv was barnaby jones or
matlock
you know it was
[Applause]
did you see that trump was on nbc uh joe
was on abc i was on
thc it's the only way i could get
through this
and
and of course the democrats you know
they always [ __ ] up the optics yeah
oh [ __ ] as i say as i fall off the riser
i [ __ ] up the optic completely these
morons
fix that [ __ ] but uh
but biden's questioners were above him
so he was
always looking up you know and squinting
he looked like clint eastwood trying to
decide to change a light bulb
but the trump one was just amazing trump
defended retweeting this crazy
conspiracy theory did you see this
about how bin laden wasn't really killed
by obama because of course obama never
could do anything good so he didn't even
do that
it was a body double and then obama had
seal team six
murdered to cover it up
trump said that defended this and then
which led to an undecided voter from
bridgeport connecticut to ask a
follow-up question
are you on bath salts
and the moderator savannah guthrie
this was great she actually said you're
the president not someone's crazy uncle
apparently she has not read the book by
trump's niece called
my crazy uncle i mean there's actually a
book about my crazy uncle
so no it's getting so crazy the october
surprise
that the trump people have now have you
seen this it's hunter biden's
laptop joe biden's near dewell son
hunter
has this laptop which apparently had
incriminating evidence
with you know maybe stuff about
influence peddling on it that was
contained in his emails
and apparently you know according to
this hunter was trading on his name
selling access to his father accepting
money for nothing
what don jr calls living the dream
and but here's the part that gets a
little squirrely about the story how do
we know
about these emails well apparently don
jr i'm not done
hunter took his computer which wasn't
working to a computer repair shop as we
all do in 2020
do we okay maybe i don't know the
computer and left it there and forgot
about it because
says rudy giuliani i won't even get into
how he's in this because he was drunk
and the the computer repairman is blind
i'm not making that part of the story up
no i i swear to god it's in the paper
legally blind
so how the blind man knew hunter was
drunk how you
how you repair a computer if you're
blind i don't know about that either
but in the process of repairing hunter's
computer blindly
he read again don't ask
hunter's emails and turned it over to
the fbi
is that how you fix a laptop nowadays
you read somebody's emails it's
it's like the plumber saying well the
problem with your pipes is you have
cocaine in your underwear drawer
and also on apparently again this we
haven't vetted this
on hunter's computer a picture of him
passed out with a hooker and a crack
pipe in his mouth
so many questions um first of all how do
we know it was a hooker
could have just been a crack enthusiast
uh
whose legs got caught in a fishing net
you know i i
[Music]
mean also who passes out on crack
is my other big question i i always
thought that
heroin yes but crack i thought that was
more of an up drug
but you know um so anyway
amid all this the hearings have been
going on with the supreme court with amy
coney barrett have you seen her this
week oh my god um you know
all these hearings are the same they're
all the same
you have a brilliant legal mind can i
ask your thoughts on a legal question
no you're in
and you know i i did call her a nut a
couple of weeks ago and the
trump administration put in an ad they
were very mad but come on
she i'm going to talk about her at the
end of the show but i got to say this
part
she was in this cult catholic church no
i mean
uh a cult within a cult
and i read this week they thought large
belt buckles
were a sin because they draw attention
to the crotch
well good luck on the supreme court
because you know what else draws
attention to the crotch
clarence thomas going look at my crotch
um
but trump they think this is helping
them with the supreme court i don't know
trump is bleeding support
with suburban women he was begging them
this is not a paraphrase this is what
trump said word for word
the other day in pennsylvania he said
suburban women
will you please like me
you're so desperate it's like one of
those desperate husbands honey i can
change
we'll take a trip you know he's ending
his rallies by playing
ymca i'm not kidding
a gay anthem about hooking up at the y
i this tells me two things trump doesn't
know what the song is about
and lindsey graham is in charge of the
music that's what this tells me
and you know it's not just among women
he's losing among all white voters
this is becoming a very unpopular ticket
flies have stopped landing on mike pence
oh they asked kamala about that this
week she said she did notice during the
debate that the fly
landed on him but she said it was very
confusing because during debate prep
they told her if you want to make
mike pence nervous stare at his fly
you